[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París un programa de
radiofrance internacional en
colaboración con Franz 24 en español en
el que damos la palabra cada semana
representantes de la cultura las
ciencias las artes la política y claro
Está también de la sociedad civil este
2023 se conmemoran los 40 años del fin
de la dictadura militar Argentina una
dictadura que marcó a ese país con más
de 30.000 desaparecidos miles de muertos
y sobre todo una guerra que aún sigue
presente la guerra de las malvinas está
con nosotros Leyla guerriero una de las
mejores representantes de la literatura
narrativa en América Latina premio de la
fundación Gabo en honor a Gabriel García
Márquez y autora del libro La otra
guerra la otra guerra que comienza a
circular esta semana gracias a la
editorial Payo rivash Leila un placer
tenerla con nosotros Gracias por
otorgarnos esta primacía para esta
entrevista sobre su libro no por favor
Braulio Gracias a ustedes por la
invitación un placer bienvenida cuatro
décadas rápidamente y sin embargo son
cuatro décadas que han marcado todavía
hasta el día de hoy a esa sociedad
Argentina el libro que usted narra la
otra guerra es la división entre unos
Héroes forzados a veces jóvenes
militares que fueron llevados a una
masacre usados como Carne de cañón pero
que al mismo tiempo en algunas ocasiones
eran miembros eran torsionarios de la
junta militar Argentina sí es una guerra
compleja la guerra de malvinas porque
precisamente marcó por un lado el final
de La dictadura militar que había
empezado en 1976 como mencionaste una
dictadura completamente carnicera
criminal
y por otra parte fue una guerra en la
cual se mezclaron estas dos Dos clases
de combatientes digamos soldados rasos
que estaban incluso haciendo lo que
Nosotros llamamos el servicio militar
que en ese momento era obligatorio que
es como el entrenamiento militar que
tenían que hacer los varones argentinos
a partir de los 18 años por algunos
meses y soldados de militares de carrera
no todos ellos represores pero muchos de
ellos que habían tenido participación en
la represión militar entonces esa guerra
dejó una cantidad de caídos y decaídos
en la cual se mezclaron estos estos
estas distintas facciones digamos y
había desde chicos muy jóvenes hasta
militares que no habían tenido nada que
ver con la con la con la dictadura en
términos de no participar en actividades
represivas y represores y todos ellos
quedaron cubiertos Bajo el mismo manto
de la palabra Héroes lo cual complica
mucho las cosas porque estamos muy de
acuerdo en que algunos hilos se dan pero
no todos estamos de acuerdo en que otros
sean Héroes de malvinas habiendo
torturados secuestrado etcétera el libro
comienza con una imagen que es bastante
expresiva estamos el día 30 de marzo de
1982 alrededor de 50.000 personas van a
reunirse en la Plaza de Mayo la Plaza
Central de Buenos Aires para protestar
contra La dictadura militar sabiendo que
la manifestaciones estaban prohibidas la
Consigna es Pampas y trabajo no y tres
días después apenas tres días después el
2 de abril más de 100.000 personas se
reúnen en la misma Plaza de Mayo para
vitorear a Leopoldo galtieri el
dirigente de la junta militar porque
había iniciado la guerra de las malvinas
se puede decir que el Patriotismo el
chovinismo el nacionalismo nunca han
sido buenos consejeros No creo que no
nunca ha sido no han sido buenos
consejeros y yo creo que en esa en esa
escena que vos describiste también se ve
un poco como la semilla la Simiente de
lo que iba a pasar después en torno a
todo lo que dejó malvinas esas
contradicciones no Esta esta este
nacionalismo exacerbado por parte de
alguna gente incluso por parte de los
familiares de los caídos que reivindican
la gesta de malvinas como una gesta
justa digamos
y la
la vergüenza o el oprobio que siente
parte también del pueblo argentino
digamos por haber sido esta una guerra
que fue propiciada por una dictadura
militar y que paradójicamente significó
también la caída de esa dictadura porque
perdieron ellos digamos de alguna manera
propiciaron esta guerra porque venía su
popularidad en declive y creyeron que
con esa guerra iban a de alguna forma
retomar ese caudal de popularidad si es
que existía no lo lograron nosotros no
lo lograron sino que además perdieron y
esa popularidad bajó muchísimo más
entonces allí en esa escena seminal yo
creo que se reúnen todas las
contradicciones que después iban a
florecer de manera muy dramática para
mucha gente sobre todo para los
familiares de los caídos en malvinas de
los combatientes rasos digamos
ciertamente esa guerra dura exactamente
72 días
dos meses y medio hay más de 600
militares y oficiales argentinos que
mueren y lo que sucede es Y ahí empieza
se puede decir la propia historia de su
libro porque que es muchos de esos
militares de esas Víctimas de esos
muertos van a quedarse en las en las
islas malvinas desconocidos no
identificados háblenos de esa situación
Bueno cuando terminó la guerra quedaron
muchos cadáveres de combatientes
argentinos
diseminados por la isla algunos
enterrados con una cruz con un nombre
por sus propios compañeros pero muchos
de los cuerpos como ya ha terminado la
batalla estaban en la superficie y
Inglaterra envió a un oficial muy joven
llamado Jeffrey Cardozo que es una pieza
nodal en la historia que es una pieza
nodal Jeffrey que llegó con otra tarea
la tarea de él era reconfortar un poco a
las tropas británicas este como digamos
antes del regreso a casa y encontró
estos cuerpos argentinos esparcidos por
toda la isla pidió orden a sus
superiores permiso más bien de para
enterrarlos le dijeron que sí porque era
algo humanitario y la verdad es que hizo
una tarea
de enterrador de fúnebrero muy
[Música]
porque volvió a los cuerpos Busco carnet
de identidad a los que la tenían los
envolvió de manera tal que quedaran como
como protegidos de un clima muy hostil
muy húmedo etcétera los enterró Pero
había 200 cuerpos que no tenían ningún
tipo de identificación
casi 200 cuerpos entonces este a estos
cuerpos les puso una cruz de madera muy
simple con una inscripción que decía
soldado argentino solo conocido por Dios
Y estos cuerpos quedaron allí durante
muchísimos años Inglaterra envió a la
dictadura militar un oficio
ofreciendo la posibilidad de que se
enviaran
peritos a reconocer los cuerpos y
repatriarlos y la palabra repatriarlos
fue el problema de todo lo que después
determinó 40 años de silencio
prácticamente porque la dictadura dijo
que no se repatria lo que está en el
suelo propio no exactamente perdón hay
dos palabras que revienen regularmente
en el libro que son claves
repatriamiento uno y el otro es
desaparecido no pasar el término
desaparecido porque los desaparecidos
son las víctimas de la junta militar y
al mismo tiempo el repartimiento No
porque las malvinas es considerada parte
de la Argentina Pero además de
patriarlos significa que dejar el
terreno de las malvinas en manos de los
británicos claro los familiares de los
de estas de estas personas que están
enterradas Sin nombre o los que están
enterrados con nombre
de se niegan a todo traslado de los
cuerpos porque el cementerio que es el
cementerio en la zona que se llama
Darwin en malvinas
de alguna forma Ellos lo sienten como
una especie de bueno de bandera de
bastión argentino clavado allí y digamos
que consideran que simbólicamente quitar
esos cuerpos de allí es retirar la
última presencia Argentina y resignar de
alguna forma un lugar de pertenencia
como decir estamos aquí son nuestras no
Pero bueno así se mezclan también
otras cosas que son interesantes que es
de parte de los familiares de los caídos
pensamientos también
muy nacionalistas con lo cual eso
empieza a complicar un poco las cosas
porque demuestro por lo menos yo pienso
eso que las víctimas
no tienen por qué ser siempre víctimas
perfectas no gente que que piensa como a
uno le gusta que tiene la ideología que
a uno le gusta
muchos de los familiares decaídos
estuvieron mucho que ver con con el
hecho de que no se pudiera identificar
estos cuerpos durante casi 40 años se
oponían se oponían a esto porque hay que
decir que una vez terminada la guerra se
va a crear la comisión de familiares de
soldades caídos en las malvinas y en las
islas del Atlántico Sur incluso miembros
de esa asociación muchos de ellos son
militares que son los que se oponen
precisamente al repatriamiento de los
soldados Sí de hecho la persona que
fundó esta asociación es un militar un
militar de carrera fallecido
y esta esta gente digamos amparada en
Estas ideas este nacionalistas
impedían y pidieron durante mucho tiempo
todo tipo de avance aún cuando estaba
toda la tecnología del ADN desarrollada
impidieron que estos estas
identificaciones se hicieran sin de
alguna forma
Tener información Clara ellos o precisa
lo que se iba a hacer se negaban a todo
tipo de explicación estaban convencidos
de que iban a levantar todos los cuerpos
de que los iban a sacar de allí fue un
proceso sumamente largo y que empieza un
poco con este caballero inglés Jeffrey
Cardozo en una larga serie de azares y
de encuentros fortuitos y todo que
precisamente el libro sí que es un poco
no sé parece casi un cuento no dos
personas un excombatiente argentino y
Jeffrey Cardozo se encuentran en un bar
de Londres en el año
2008-2009 por allí hay una terapia
postraumática por lo de la Guerra el
medio de una terapia postraumática por
lo de la guerra y Jeffrey Cardozo que
había este informe muy específico y muy
detallado y lo había entregado a la
junta militar argentina
se encuentra con este señor Julio aro
excombatiente de malvinas
y empiezan a conversar como pueden
porque
español ni Julio habla inglés y entonces
este Jeffrey le dice Bueno Julio se
queja de que de que de que bueno de que
esos soldados Siguen sin Identificar y
Jeffrey dice cómo no los identificaron
todavía si yo dejé un informe diciendo
dónde estaba cada quien y Julio le dice
qué informe y esa pregunta en ese
momento Jeffrey le entrega el informe y
Julio se lo lleva a la Argentina de
regreso y cuando lo empieza a mirar este
me dijo literalmente que quería aprender
fuego todo porque se dio cuenta de que
durante 30 y algo de años la información
de dónde estaba cada avión había estado
escondida estamos hablando de su libro
pero no hablamos de la autora del libro
leyéndola a mí me dio la impresión de
que usted se ASUME como una especie de
transmisora de testimonios que ha
recibido para que la gente pueda recibir
esa historia A veces leyendo las páginas
de libros como subiendo estuviera
masticando vidrio son páginas que duelen
Bueno espero que espero que sea una
metáfora que no sea literal lo demás
sí Mira yo la verdad es que traté de
escribir el libro
con un estilo no tratando de no subrayar
la tragedia porque ya la tragedia era
cientos de familiares Viajando en el
tiempo sin saber dónde están sus hijos
sin poder ir a verlos como Rehenes
también de una ideología encontrada
entre digo para el Estado el tema de
malvinas mandar un equipo identificar
Los Caídos Será muy complicado porque
era ponerse en contra los familiares
Precisamente lo cual era políticamente
muy riesgoso y en esta en esta situación
había muchos familiares que sí hubieran
querido que fueran identificados pero
que se tenía que quedar callados la boca
digamos entonces la tragedia era tan
grande que yo traté de bueno de alguna
forma atemperar el el estilo
transformarlo en un estilo muy brutal
muy seco muy directo yo creo igual que
tengo un estilo un seco acético
astringente que no es un estilo barroco
que creo que no no está más entroncado
en alguna tradición norteamericana de
narración que en la narración
latinoamericana Pues estamos llegando ya
al final de esta escala en París no me
queda sino agradecerle a Leila guerriero
su presencia en nuestros estudios
gracias por haber venido y unas mucho
éxito por la otra guerra lo otra guerra
a ustedes les damos las gracias y Les
esperamos en una nueva cita aquí la
próxima semana en otra escala en París